hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game from round three of the
costume of Memorial if you're wondering
if it's really me or some imposter I you
know I assure you it's really me it's
again between Vishwanathan Anand and
chocolate Mahmoud Yara we already seen
the game between Magnus cross and David
navara I hope you enjoyed that game if
you haven't I will put a link to it in
the description below so feel free to
follow that one as well it's a really
interesting game as mama Gandalf
prepares a deviation from the line Anand
already played against our onion in the
2016 candidates tournament but you'll
see what I mean by this let's just check
it out and I did prepare the standings
after round three so I do hope I don't
forget that after the game Anand opened
with e4 we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight
to c6 and Bishop to c4 we have the
Italian game Bishop to c5 and now I'm
not I'm not even gonna joke about it
here on and adjust castles we have nice
to f6 d3 we have d6 + c3 so this is a
like I said
Anand already played this game against
our onion in the 2016 candidates and the
Mahmud era was following that game with
would have prepared deviation with a 4
by Anand pretty standard in the Italian
you wanna grab more space on the Queen
side Bishop to e7 are not allowing the B
for expansion to come with tempo the
bishop is safely tucked in on a 7 with
nice to a3 by white knights the e7 and
now Knight back to C - just remembering
when the bishop comes - sorry not the
Queen when the bishop comes to e3 the
knight from CT will be ready to
recapture if black decides to do so with
Knight to g6 black also remembers the
night Bishop to e3 and now in the game
we mentioned our Anand versus Oregon in
the 2016 candidates tournament our onion
castled here and Anand Anand was able to
win this game so here we have Bishop
captures on e3 immediately and it is as
of this move on move 10 we have a
completely new game now soak a nice
chapters on e3 and here we have just
gases and it's a similar position I mean
it
pretty much the same position as island
headed against our onion but the trade
of dark square bishop happened on a7
instead of on e3 so here in that game it
was this exact same position only the
rook was on a seven so as there's no
merit for the rook to be an a7 mommy
decided it was better just to grab the
bishop on e3 right away Queen to c2 by
aren't connecting groups developing the
Queen
we have c6 preparing b5 now we have a
five for grabbing more space on the
Queen side and now just d5 we have
Bishop back to b3 and now although you
could push d4 white will just ignore you
it's just gonna play Knight c4 and then
you're gonna have to capture and the
white will still keep a very strong
center just you know connectbooks put in
to d1 e1 + d 4 and I'm gonna have a
really nice game so here after Bishop to
b3 you have Bishop to e6 by black he
captures on d5 C chapters on d5 and now
d4 we have E for closing up this nice
diagonal for the Queen and also pushing
the night somewhere back nice to e5 and
excellent central square for the knight
and now of course you don't want to
capture as it doesn't bring you anything
Queen to d6 but it's not trying
threatening to capture on e5 with f4 and
now you're either gonna keep this knight
on e5 which is now pretty much an
excellent piece or you could just force
it back which mama Europe does with he
captures on f3 on Poisson Knight goes
back as now there's again the threat of
Knight captures on e5 and we have just
rook e8 e8 rook F the e1 also opposing
the rook along the e-file and Bishop to
d7 with ideas of Bishop to b5 where the
rook and Bishop will nicely be
controlling the e2 square but that will
come handy later in the game here if you
look at the position the material on the
board is equal one difference you might
notice is that black is three point
islands on it has only two point islands
so the d5 pawn is an isolated pawn and
here already the bishop and Knight are
attacking it here on plays g3 takes away
the f4 and h4 square from Mahmud arrows
Knights but also
Paris Queen to G to the pile up against
the d5 pawn alongside the knight and the
bishop with h6 making some breathing
room for the king but also not allowing
the night the g5 square we have Queen to
g2 and now already three pieces are
lying that the five point of this Knight
moves you will be able to capture it so
here mama Dara finds a very nice way of
defending it a rook to e7 which is very
nice now if you go something like nice
to see to just night the c2 was played
in the game what I meant to say is if
you play something like night to d2 just
open up a triple attack against the d5
pawn then black is able to defend the
defect or indirectly by doubling looks
on the e-file and now you will not be
capturing anything as your rook on e1 is
very weak now so instead of that night
to d2 we have nights to see - now on is
Rima nuvaring this night to come to be
four to pile up on the d5 pawn from
there with rook F to e eight doubling up
and now nice to be 4s planned and then
our Bishop to b5 again going for that
very nice a to square we have rook
captures on e7 rook captures on e7 and
now now you have to be careful rook to
e2 would be an excellent move for black
so are not prevented by going back up to
d1 which is yes you are preventing the
the rook from infiltrating the
second-ranked but then again your rook
is unable to join join in the all the
action
h5 here mama Dara prepares h4 and he
wants to bust open the Kings side with
Queen to h3 preparing to meet h4 with
the just captures and the Bishop to d7
pushing on on screen back Queen g2 we
have pushed back to b5 and Queen back to
h3 and on this testing mummy djaro you
know to see what's what is he interested
in repeating moves or will he try
something else and here my material does
go h4 just just a nice pawn push and
even though you are you are defending
the h4 square three times the night is
also guarding the e1 Square and the
bishop has cut off the Rose
so v1 so you will not be capturing on h4
here rush up to see - it's important
that the rook is now able to control the
the first rank and that rook to e2 now
isn't all that big of a deal so first we
have pawn captures now comes Queen
captures hoping to trade Queens but mama
D are just blocks it with Knight to f4
already with some very nasty threats
like Knight to e2 check would pick up
the Queen
so King - h1 getting out of the way and
now comes look - III and you can see
that so many of Mahmud our species are
piling up in front of the in front of
the King also the bishop on this
diagonal very you know a very
influential Bishop so here we have rook
to g1 first and threatens checkmate you
have to deal with this we have G sets by
Musharraf and now Queen to f2 attacking
the rook here look to e2 and only now
Queen come that comes back to h4 so what
do you do here well white also has a
couple of threats here for example
Knight is definitely coming to e5 which
blocks the Queen's attack towards the h2
pawn also you will attack the the g6
pawn the f7 point so white will also
have a very nice attack here so what do
you do here blacks the best idea is to
go Knights to h1 a h5 you do want to
close up the H file what this will just
will only become apparent after a few
moves because in the game um you're up
late nights to e4 instead of h5 and here
Anand found well a very nice a very nice
prevention of Mahmud Arabs attack he
just played Bishop captures on e4 d
captures on e4 and now tonight's the e5
here again just just a very nice piece
this night and what do you do here the
night now blocks the Queen's defense of
the night here so Queen captures Knight
is a threat if you move the knight back
for example here then Queen to f6 will
be very strong with wood a lot of
threats possible here so with all this
hanging in the air mommy I've played
nice to d3 and here he missed one well
he didn't miss it it's you have to allow
it I don't know if he missed it or or it
was just a bonus that that night the DS
is in fact the best move but here feel
free to pause the video and try to
the best move for Anand in this position
I'll give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent you
know
winner winner of pawns and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the game here
aren't played Queen to h8 check and yeah
it's just wonderful move especially when
you're able to play it the King has to
capture and now of course the f7 pawn
will be lost
mommy there have captured the Queen we
have knife captures on f7 now for King
the king and the Queen King to h7 and
now Knight character son b6 and here
again it's it's a very delicate position
best for mummy Europe is 91 with ideas
of knife to f3 while pressuring the the
h2 pawn but mama girl went Bishop to d7
and here Anand just captured the e4 pawn
it doesn't matter that the knight will
be captured because the pawn was
defending the knight on d3 so if rook
captures Knight captures night on d3
here mama D are played Bishop to f5 and
Anand just played Knight g5 check King
to h6 and the now comes Knight captures
on d3 Bishop captures and rook to g3
pressuring the bishop with rook to e1
check King to g2 and the now a few
checks will follow our repeater check
kim ji-won rook e1 check King to have to
look at e to check and now King to f3
and here mama Yara doesn't miss out an
opportunity to grab a pawn we look after
son b2 and now King to f4 so if you look
at this position mummy there we'll grab
the h2 point as well Anand is not
interested in wasting time in preserving
that pawn he is the only one with a
passed pawn here it's a fast epon and he
wants to bring his King all the way up
to c7 to start pushing the pawn so
Bishop to a5 not allowing this Bishop to
be captured we have King to e5 now and
rook captures on h2 so mamakara of
equalizes in material but as you can see
the position of our valance King is much
better here and wants to play King d6
can see 5 start pushing the passed pawn
and win the game whereas black doesn't
really have all that many options of
pushing the pawns
yes by capturing the h2 pawn G pawn has
been
promoted to a passport but it's it's not
as fast as Islands deep on so night to
f7 checked we have King to g7 and not
knife to d6 with ideas of capturing the
bishop first rookie to check with King
to d5 and now King to f6 and an unjust
plays c4 we have rook to e7 and now
comes a rook to f3 rook to d7 hoping to
stifle White's advancement but then
comes c5 rogue back to East 7 and now
rook to f2 by Anand look to h7 and here
finally undecided to capture we have
nice captures G captures now the G porn
has became a passed F pawn and now King
to d6 so K the King still cannot advance
due to the rug being and the salmon
Frank but it doesn't matter as black
also has to make a move here rook to h8
was played and the now comes looked to
d2 you have passed pawn you have to put
a row behind a passed pawn if you if you
wish to push it we have F for black
starts pushing his own passport and but
now King to c7 and finally on its king
reached his destination the c7 square
and it is not all that clear how black
can do something about this monkey art
of played rook to h7 check with King to
c8 now and after f3 one last push by
black are not simply play d5 and it was
in this position almost 63 that shocker
mayara resigned the game and a wonderful
victory for vishwanathan anand who lost
an unfortunate game yesterday to Magnus
Carlsen and he had a winning game
against Navarro in round 1 but he didn't
he didn't find the best continuation so
I well deserved a win for the former
world champion Vishwanathan Anand what
is black resigned well there's nothing
to do here you don't really have any
good checks if you check then you lose
all of the Queen side pawns then the
position will be very easily winning you
don't have any ways of starting to push
your own passport pass to the second
rank and if black does nothing where I
mean black doesn't really have any moves
or White's next move will be d6 d7 and
the
eight what will bring a queen into the
game and easily win the game so like I
said 63 mommy designed the game and a
wonderful victory for Ireland in round
three of the costume of Memorial the
sixth edition of it at that and like I
said I did prepare the standing so these
are the standings after round three
Magnus Carlsen in first place with two
and a half out of three so so far world
champion is having an excellent
tournament we have Dingley rain in in
second place I know you guys were asking
me to show the dings Liang Liang's
victory what I haven't got the time here
to show that one if we will have a slow
round then we'll get back to that one to
show it also with two points area
cracking after his victory against
onigiri onigiri failed to sacrifice the
bishop on e6 and start a wonderful
attack he missed this opportunity and
kurakin was able to win the game
then anand after this victory with a
point and a half they're a team order
job of a vessel in top all of also with
one point and a half and then with 14.4
people alexander green shook onigiri
Shankly remedial and david navara so i
mean in this tournament it doesn't
really matter anyone anyone who will be
having a bad term and you will say oh
how come he's having a betterment but
someone always has to have a bad
tournament unless you'll have like
everyone draws every game every round
but yeah I'm still hoping to see hoping
to see a brutal game but Apollo this
tournament if possible it would be very
interesting how about yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it and that
you're enjoying my short coverage of the
regime of Memorial so far once again I
would like to thank Allen ferns Michael
Hildebrand Paul staples Manish meanwhile
in the research solely for a
contribution to my channel thank you
what I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos ER think
of for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content and and whatnot
thank you all and have an excellent rest
of your day or evening and I will see
you soon